have you been practicing your to see
slide yeah I've been putting in like a
couple hours every single day mm-hmm
yeah I'm almost there
yeah like it looks smooth but it's like
you know exiting it it could be better
you know like I get the Tuesday slide
but then like after you know in the
video where he kind of does that little
dance in the foyer or whatever like
right after he's done Tuesday sliding
that I'm not quite like is that you can
really add your own Flair there and I
just don't quite have it yet so I'm
still working on it I like how this
[ __ ] waited till everyone was
locked in a house yeah yeah yeah he
probably started working on the song
right as quarantine started he was like
this is it yeah did you see look at pull
up the video didn't just mute it but
pulled the did you watch the music video
yeah I'm as [ __ ] house yeah his palace
his pose his his his pose you see his
[ __ ] Drake's [ __ ] I hate that he used
this [ __ ] like YouTube lyric video
font as I now I look so like fake I know
dude we got to talk about kwibi - oh
yeah yeah we can you know we can talk
about that after yeah his house is
insane this dude is not in quarantine
this dude is in like he's in a museum
yeah like this [ __ ] is like a government
building no it's way nicer than a oh
you're talking about like like a
Parliament building
yeah just like like structure and look
at this [ __ ] I know it's ridiculous how
I would be I would be scared to like to
even walk in there I feel the floors are
worth more than entire neighborhoods I
don't really get living in a house like
this because this wouldn't feel like a
home to me oh it feels super cold it
feels like a night like a super nice
hotel doesn't it yeah like in Dubai or
something yeah or even you know just
like a boutique hotel somewhere either
way I don't think I loved about this
dance is it just it's easy right there
that's why I'm talking
afterwards see ya he's adding his own
thing there you know that's the
opportunity for us to input our creative
idea right I was still rising the dance
itself still just shown the guy screams
boredom I think like he knows they said
he consulted with like dancers for this
song and who said that it Drake did
apparently he like consulted with
dancers when making this song where'd
you read that Drake consulted dancers
fourth lad and that's the best they
could come up with that's what I was
saying is I'm like left foot up right
foot slide as [ __ ] as boring as hell
it's simpler than any wedding dance but
yeah here here here he turned to a few
dancers for help to see aoao and Heike
are popular dancers only used oh okay
sorry I didn't realize they meant
[ __ ] Tik Tok creators nevermind
well I got baited jebaited [ __ ]
deleted all I'm saying dude is like once
we master this back to see a lot of tik
toks from me
in the next week let's just say that
dude lives in a [ __ ] like consulate
building yes that's crazy he lives in
the embassy it's just the director it's
just a drake canadian embassy yeah and
the only ambassador is just drake
goddamn dude he represents the nation of
drake in canada that's so his place in
Toronto right um
I mean yeah I mean I just I assume he
lived nowhere else unless this isn't
like Calabasas which I doubt but I think
he has a place in Kelvin who gives a
[ __ ] gives an absolute [ __ ] what what a
[ __ ] luxury this guy has lives in
this goddamn white house building and
he's like I feel like making more
money and then he just makes this song
and then he hits of all these tick tock
craters and he's like what's what would
you like in a dance
I wonder if him all this input and he
was like no what about right foot up
left foot slide what about that yeah or
like they're like ant and he's like
that's it
oh no then we'll do it on the other side
no they probably like gave him some
dance that he couldn't do I can't do
this they're probably like you could
like do this with your knees and get low
and then like oh but he's like yeah now
I'm not doing all that and then body
roll and then he's like yeah stop you a
body roll
you